y'a aucune solution si on regarde la
position donnée par les britanniques
parce qu'en fait tout part d'un mensonge
cirque on nous a expliqué le nous ils
ont expliqué les partisans du break cite
notamment monsieur faradje et tous ses
amis que l'on pouvait être à la fois
dedans et dehors c'est à dire qu'en gros
on allait avoir les avantages mais pas
les inconvénients bah voyons
et donc là on s'aperçoit que leur
discours était un discours mensonger et
qui a pas de solution sur leurs bases
en réalité là on s'oriente vers une
solution qui va être le pire de ce qui
pouvait arriver aux défenseurs du bric
site c'est à dire que pour ne pas
remettre en cause l'accord entre les
deux vies reland et ravivé effectivement
ces années sanglantes et et de
terrorisme et de d2 et de souffrance
ils vont être obligés à ce stade et
enfin m'expliquer comment soin de faire
tout sortir ce qui est inimaginable pour
l'irlande qui va jamais accepter de
sortir de l'union européenne soit
d'avoir les mêmes règles partout et donc
l'angleterre va se retrouver avec
l'obligation de respecter l'ensemble des
normes européennes pour ne pas remettre
de frontières entre les deux irlande et
entre le royaume uni et la l'irlande et
en même temps ne pourra plus participer
aux décisions